the murder scene
a police sergeant shot dead inside a
police building
by a man already under arrest and
handcuffed
the victim was matthew ratner a london
police officer for 29 years
looking forward to retirement
he was highly regarded by his devastated
colleagues
many in disbelief at what happened his
colleagues
knew him as a big guy
big in stature begin hard
friendly capable
a lovely man highly respected by his
colleagues
officers staff and of course
by members of the public welcome to east
queensland rugby football club
i'm matt ratner head coach this was matt
ratana at the rugby club he loved
east grinstead in east sussex he was
appointed head coach last year
after a long spell coaching younger
players
he had a partner and a grown-up son from
a previous relationship
but scotland yard a minute silence at
the same time officers were trying to
contact the victim's family
in his native new zealand
the suspect a 23 year old man had been
stopped and searched in the early hours
by two constables
it's alleged they found drugs and
ammunition on him
he was arrested and driven to croydon
custody center
according to the independent office for
police conduct
when the prisoner got here he was taken
into a holding area seated
with his hands cuffed behind him as
officers prepared to search him with a
metal detector
it's thought he produced a revolver and
opened fire
then apparently shot himself
counter-terror officers are being kept
informed but at the moment
terror isn't seen as a motive for the
attack
i'm deeply shocked and saddened by the
tragic killing of the officer in croydon
overnight all our thoughts are with the
officers
family friends and colleagues across
metropolitan police force
but also police and family across the
country
there were so many questions not just
for the murdered officers colleagues
how well was the suspect searched how
did he get a gun
inside a police station and how if he
was handcuffed
was he able to use it with such deadly
effect
martin brunt sky news croydon